Bethesda gets approached about making
movies all the time but so far the
studio hasn't budged so what would it
take to bring something like the Elder
Scrolls to the big screen according to
executive Pete Hines Bethesda would
gladly sit down with director Peter
Jackson best known for The Lord of the
Rings trilogy if he were interested in
an interview with finder huynh set of
his board of directors it's not like we
don't know where to go if we want to get
a film or TV show made it's more about
is this something we really want to do I
think if Peter Jackson showed up and
said I want to do Elder Scrolls well
that would be a pretty serious
conversation you would have to listen to
but I think Peter is probably pretty
busy so I don't see us anytime soon
looking at movies Bethesda is actually
very well positioned if it does decide
to make a film pirates of the caribbean
Jerry Bruckheimer and former MGM CEO
Harry Sloan are both on the company's
board of directors if the studio
announces anything down the road you'll
hear about it from GameSpot and for all
the latest news on elder scrolls and
other big RPGs you're already in the
right place
you